dos nuevos tiroteos masivos que
reafirman la problemática de la
violencia Armada en Estados Unidos en la
noche del sábado la ciudad de Louisville
en el estado de Kentucky volvió a ser
escenario de un nuevo tiroteo en un
parque público que dejó dos muertos y
cuatro personas heridas cinco días antes
en la misma urbe otro ataque armado en
un banco de 5 muertos y cuatro heridos
esta ha sido una semana
indescriptiblemente Trágica para nuestra
ciudad el lunes perdimos a cinco de
nuestros conciudadanos en un horrible
acto de violencia Armada en un lugar de
trabajo
y ahora cinco días después estamos en
otra escena de un acto imprudente de
violencia Armada
Esta no es nuestra ciudad Esto no es lo
que somos Esto no es lo que queremos ser
también el sábado otro tiroteo en el
pueblo de David Alabama la fiesta de
cumpleaños de adolescente culminó con
cuatro muertos más y una veintena de
personas heridas Aunque todavía se
desconoce el móvil del ataque
les pido que mantengan a nuestra
comunidad en sus oraciones les pido que
mantengan a mi departamento de policía
en sus oraciones Y también les pido a
cada uno de ustedes que no dejen que
este momento defina lo que piensan sobre
la ciudad de David y nuestras buenas
personas
lo recientes tiroteos masivos se suman a
los más de 160 ataques de este tipo
registrados en lo corrido del año según
el archivo del portal gambaiolens un
escenario complejo que se enmarca en el
debate del porte de armas que los
demócratas quieren regular y una parte
de los republicanos siguen reivindicando
como un derecho constitucional todo ello
mientras se van engranando las campañas
electorales de Cara a las presidenciales
de 2024